what do you think is the role of death
in uh in all of this
the the fear of death does that
interplay with consciousness does
this self-reflection
do you think
there's some
[Music]
deep connection between this ability to
contemplate the fact that the our flame
of
of uh
consciousness eventually goes out
yeah i don't think unfortunately pan
psychism
helps particularly with life after death
because you know for the pan psychist
there's nothing
supernatural there's nothing beyond the
physical all there is really is
ultimately particles and fields it's
just that we think the ultimate nature
of particles and fields is consciousness
but
i guess when um
when the uh the the matter in my brain
ceases to be ordered in a way that
sustains the particular kind of
consciousness
uh i enjoy in waking life then
in some sense i will i i will
cease to be although i do that the final
chapter of my book galileo's error is
more
experimental so the first four chapters
are the
cold-blooded case for the panzerkist
view is that the best
solution to the hard problem of
consciousness the last chapter we talk
about meaning yeah i talk about meaning
you talk about free will and i talk
about mystical experiences so
i always want to emphasize that
pan psychism is not necessarily
connected to anything spiritual you know
a lot of people defending this view like
david sharma's or luke roloffs are just
total atheist secularists right they
don't believe in
any kind of transcendent reality they
just believe in
feelings you know mundane consciousness
and think that needs explaining in our
conventional scientific approach can't
cut it
but
if
for independent reasons you are
motivated to some spiritual
picture of reality then maybe a
panseika's view is is more consonant
with that so if you
if you have a mystical experience where
you um
it seems to you in this experience that
there is this
higher form of consciousness at the root
of all things
if you're a materialist you've got to
think that's a delusion you know there's
just something in your brain making you
think that it's not real
but if you're a psychist and you already
think
the fundamental nature of reality is
constituted of consciousness it's not
that much of a leap
to think that um
this higher form of consciousness you
seem to apprehend in the mystical
experience is part of that underlying
reality
and you know in in many different
cultures experienced meditators
have claimed to have experiences
in which it becomes apparent to them
that
there is an element of consciousness
that is universal so this is sometimes
called universal consciousness
so
on this view
your mind and my mind are not
totally distinct
uh each of our individual conscious
minds is built upon the foundations of
universal consciousness and universal
consciousness as it exists in me is
one and the same thing as universal
consciousness as it exists in you
so
i've never had one of these experiences
but
if one is a pansys i think one is more
open to that possibility i don't see why
it shouldn't be the case that
that is part of the nature of
consciousness and maybe something that
is apparent in certain
deep states of meditation and so what i
explore in the experimental final
chapter of my book is that could allow
for a kind of impersonal
life after death because if that view is
true then even when the
particular
aspects of my conscious experience fall
away
that
element of universal consciousness at
the core of my identity would continue
to exist
so i'd sort of be as it were absorbed
into universal consciousness so i mean
buddhists and hindu mystics
try to meditate to get rid of all the
bad karma to
be absorbed into universal consciousness
it could be that
if uh if there's no karma if there's no
reverb maybe everyone gets enlightened
when they die maybe you uh just sink
back into universal consciousness
you